on march 2nd spacex ceo
elon musk announced his plan to create a
new city called
star base in what is now boko chika
village
a tiny unincorporated community of about
30 homes
located next to the southernmost beach
in texas
musk's tweet and his updates encouraging
his followers to move to the brownsville
south padre
area has created a surge of interest in
local real estate
mostly from outside buyers we probably
will not see anything like this
in our lifetime who knows if browns will
ever have an opportunity like this again
we certainly haven't in the past
but while many in the state welcome the
increased investment
and jobs some in south texas worried
that spacex's
expansion will come at a steep price to
the local people
and the environment they in effect have
shut down me personally and economically
they nickeled and dimed us to death
spacex did not respond to multiple
requests
for comment the question now is how will
elon musk build his gateway to mars
in the face of a local backlash
the conflict centers around control of a
state highway
that is the only road to both spacex's
rocket testing site
and a beloved community beach texas
highway 4
which is known locally as bokuchiko
boulevard is a two-lane road
that stretches from the shores of
bokuchika beach to the city of
brownsville
after he did his tweet it really changed
things a lot
craig grove has been a real estate
broker in the brownsville area
for 11 years we get calls like i said
from all over
the united states and even outside the
united states my phone volume i have a
answering service it's probably doubled
or quadrupled
i know of properties that were on the
market
for a good long time that didn't sell
and now because of elon's tweet they
ended up going for
you know cash offers if even a fraction
of what
spacex wants to do happens it's going to
change the face of brownsville
a lot of the people that live in these
houses are spacex engineers
and then if you look behind me over here
this is a brand new subdivision
that's going to be opening up so you can
see
it's happening spacex has had a
footprint in bogochica
since 2012 but the aerospace company
didn't begin ramping up work at the site
until 2019
when it began scaling up development of
its starship spacecraft
starship is the largest playing object
ever
made this is the same vehicle nasa
recently selected to return humans to
the moon
in 2024 best memories of my life are
right here
on this beach now i have to check if
it's okay to go
bobby lerma still lives down the street
from the beach on land
that has been in his family for five
generations
i would like to describe boca chica
beach as a paradise
this is what i want to protect i want my
kids and grandkids to come here
like i did until
recently bocachica which sits at the
edge of a national wildlife refuge
was a favorite spot for locals looking
for a quiet escape
endangered sea turtles and ocelots call
the refuge home
as well as scores of migratory birds but
since spacex began expanding its
operations in 2019
conservationists worry that the eventual
environmental impact
will be devastating
in just a few years the area surrounding
boca chica
has been transformed i have to go
through ask permission to come to my own
home spacex had security of people of
their own
bossing everybody around and requiring
ids
and things that aren't necessary for a
public highway an faa spokesperson
said that in december of 2020 the agency
approved a request by spacex to increase
the closure hours to 300 hours annually
he said implementation and enforcement
of those agreements was a local matter
in texas public access to gulf coast
beaches
is a right enshrined in the state's
constitution
but in 2013 cameron county received a
special exemption from state lawmakers
to temporarily close the beach and the
highway
during rocket launches today some locals
say
this privilege has been abused and that
the frequent highway closures
have essentially privatized the beach in
a phone conversation with the journal
cameron county judge eddie trevino said
we want spacex to succeed but not at the
expense of the community
if they think they'll be able to take
over the highway or the beach they're
mistaken
texas house representative alex
dominguez said he has filed a bill to
limit beach access
closures at boca chica but he is working
with spacex officials to try to improve
beach access
without limiting spacex's allowed
closures
spacex has faced the most friction from
the residents of bogota village
not only did they move in and change the
whole tone and tenor of the place but
but they began to do 24 7 construction
which meant you know wall-to-wall people
cars traffic noise lighting
you name it cheryl stevens was a
homeowner for 15 years in the village
and grew up going to the beach like many
former boca chica village residents
stevens purchased the property thinking
it would be her retirement home
there was no way to stay i mean it was
just so stressful
over the past year multiple spacex
rockets have exploded
breaking windows scattering debris and
causing fires
i mean it was really basically the gun
to the head approach
not a lot of a negotiation on the price
and a lot of
thinly veil threats of eminent domain
steven said she sold to spacex in late
2019
for more than 139 thousand five hundred
dollars
but she characterized the company's
initial offers as unfair
and predatory for his part
bobby lermas said he will continue
speaking out about the road closures
they are kind of pesky at calling me
every day about whether i want to sell
but i'm not going anywhere and i'm not
be bullied by anybody
i'm going to fight back why because it
is my backyard so
i have to protect my backyard because
nobody else will